[Applause]  just need to stop here cutting him  blocked by davis they still have time  though seven on the clock cutting him  all the way blocked by 80  [Applause]  on a consistent basis here the jump  shots first anthony davis says no i  don't think so  it's all right i'll take it to the rack  and see if i can get a layup no i don't  think so  so a catch and shoot might be in order  first things first you got to get it in  and they do and they throw it away they  tried to get it to sadique bay  diano and who stepped in but anthony  davis  and the lakers are going to win this one  as you mentioned stu and a.d gets  another steal at the end what a  defensive effort also for anthony davis  what a quarter for russell wesley what a  comeback by this laker team the entire  team